ATISSA BANUAZIZI: In this
class, the WRAP instructors
don't participate
directly in the grading
of those presentations.
We serve more as coaches.
And that can be sort of
helpful for the students,
because they come to us, and
we're completely on their team.
We are there not to tell
them what they did wrong,
but to help them make it better.
So I mentioned that we don't
participate in the grading
of the actual presentations.
The meetings that
they have with us
are factored into their
grade to a degree.
They get a certain number
of participation points
for coming and
actively participating
in the meetings with us.
One nice thing about the way
that the class is administered
is that the WRAP instructors
are present at the final grading
meetings.
And we do give input
into how we see
the progress that the
individual students have made.
And so sometimes,
we can really speak
to the particular challenges
that the students have
overcome, the way in which
that they have really applied
themselves to do better.
And that can be a not
insignificant part
of the conversation.